[Music]
how cool is it for you to see all of
these relationships blooming and you
still stay invested once they leave the
show yes I'm totally invested and I keep
asking the producers what happened to
this one and what happened to that one I
absolutely love it it's this is a dream
job for me and said a guy who has a lot
of dream jobs yeah this is at the top of
the list Andy Cohen is still cannot get
over his gig as the host of connection I
[Applause]
think you kissed and you told them we're
not talking about the kiss on TV that's
what we've had Ramona Singer on the show
which other housewife would you like to
see come on well LuAnn is newly single
so how did you find out about that news
have you talked to her since sex I spoke
to her the day she was leaving the
country and you know I think she very
wisely is leaving the country to kind of
gather her thoughts and get it together
I think it's this all happened in front
of the cameras and what the if you see
the reunion I think you'll be surprised
because you'll begin to see the first
signs of cracks in the relationship at
the first party that reunion
you already filmed the reunion so are
you gonna be addressing it further well
I mean it takes the reunion takes on a
new meaning when you know the ending of
the story frankly so it's interesting
seeing it with through that lens and
yeah I mean you know I look forward to
talking to Lou about where she's at as
soon as I can
you think in the next season there might
be some awkward i-told-you-so tension
between the girls what do you think yes
did you see this coming I did not see it
coming but I didn't see it coming
you know what I mean yeah you know what
I think the wild thing is she had just
gotten all the other women in her corner
and rooting for her that's what that's
what's also really sad about this
I mean everybody was on our team and
like look yours clearly so happy we're
happy for you